thank you very much dr anthony fauci we
just saw there with this warning about
the omicron variant
it is the most transmissible virus of
covid that we had to deal with thus far
when you look at the pace
of the infections now
that things will get worse as we go into
the depth of the winter
and with omicron breathing down our back
things could get really bad particularly
particularly
for the unvaccinated
the cdc is projecting 1.3 million new
cases by christmas that's just next
weekend
and more than 15 000 people are expected
to pass away from covid a week
per week by january 8. dr mark siegel is
in focus now fox news contributor
professor at nyu langone medical center
so
dr siegel you always present more than
one side of the story and there always
is one
so it's really catchy omicron we get it
how dangerous is it
well let's start and thanks for the
compliment harris you do the same thing
let's start with the fact that the fear
messaging is not working if there's
anything americans that's tired are
tired of it's the constant fear
messaging and it's also single note
right it's mask it's vaccine it's
testing well we don't have the testing
we don't have the rapid testing we need
i find testing very comforting because
if you had a rapid test in your home you
could tell if you were exposed or if you
had it we don't have that but the the
masking getting mixed up with vaccines
when vaccines are much more effective is
also that single note of fear now what
is the reality regarding omicron what is
the reality well we're getting a lot of
data out of south africa in the united
kingdom now that shows that this is
milder
this appears to be a lot milder uh
that's good news but the the other issue
is that it's affecting mostly people who
are already infected or had the vaccine
already so the number of
hospitalizations in south africa was 10
times greater for delta than for this so
it seems to spread much more easily and
it seems so far to be milder that
doesn't mean it's it's a cold it means
it's more like a severe flu so far so
let me get this straight so people
who've already had it
and people who were unvaxed is that what
i heard you say are more likely to
succumb to omicron you said people
who've already been infected what does
that mean i'm glad you're i'm cl let's
clarify that if you've had omicron if
you've had a previous variant or you've
had the vaccine and are not boosted you
can get a re-infection
this variant breaks through the vaccine
and it breaks through prior variants if
you've been boosted the chances are a
lot less than you're going to get it if
you've been boosted or had a prior
variant the chances are you're going to
get a very mild case that's the key if
you've had neither the vaccine nor the
booster nor a
prior variant that's when you're at risk
for a moderate case all right i want to
clear something else up and thank you um
what are
what are we to know about all of these
mass mandates and how they figure in the
one thing that you have taught us
consecutively over the last now two
years of dealing with this nearly is
that it is grouping and large groups of
people
unmasked because you don't know what
everybody's status is in the room and i
don't mean vaccinated unvaccinated i
mean positive negative and that's where
we tend to get into trouble so what are
we going to do this holiday season when
people are
grouping together
well you just simplified it and i think
william shaftner who's a friend of mine
on cnn completely mixed this up i think
you just gave the right answer if you're
going into a very large place and there
may be a number of people there who
could be super spreaders that's when you
wear a mask if you're going into a home
where you know everybody's vaccinated or
there's no risk or little risk you're
going to ruin your whole holiday
gathering with a mask don't need to do
that masks are for large public places
where you don't know
why won't the white house tell us that
because that's so basic
well they should listen to us i bet they
watch us maybe we can help okay
all right let's move to this the cdc is
reporting startling new nationwide
coveted numbers with cases up nearly 40
percent from just last week some of this
we anticipated doctor because people are
inside now it's been nice in new york
it's about to get cold forecast so the
more we group indoors again um are we
going down a road though where it's
going to get even more
yes we are and i that's the second time
you said that really important point
that no one else is saying harris it has
to do with the idea that it's a
respiratory virus and if you're indoors
that's when it spreads the most we tend
to forget that because with this
pandemic it's been spreading in anyway
the reason it's going to get more is
because omicron is so wildly infectious
and it's a lot like measles in that
regard but a lot of us feel that it's
going to crowd out delta and we're going
to have milder infections that doesn't
mean it's over with but again if you got
vaccinated if you had a test if you get
a milder case and finally most
importantly if that pill ever gets
approved by the fda i could say oh you
have omicron let me give you the pill
bang and you feel better well look you
said the same thing about tamiflu and
that's been a game changer
perfectly you know tamiflu was a big
game
tefl was a big game changer for the for
the 2009 swine flu that i wrote about
this is the game changer here paxlovid
the the pfizer pill looks tremendous at
keeping people away from severe illness
if you diagnose this early let's get it
approved it's before the fda right now
they should approve it right away wow
you you gave us some things to hang our
hope on there that we're not hearing and
one of them is omicron could actually
crowd out delta not making it you know a
hero of any sorts but delta is
definitely as far as we know right now a
lot more deadly uh and and those are the
details that people really need to know
those who are on the fence about getting
vaccinated those who are going to maybe
say i'm not going to go to that big
crowd this weekend because i don't
really know who's there it helps people
make their own decisions
dr siegel thank you very much
always great thank you harris hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now